[Music]
the My Little Pony franchise started
back in 2010 and it's still one of the
most popular series with a huge fan base
this time My Little Pony fans showed
their artistic skills and transformed
several celebrities into actual My
Little Pony characters
wait until you see Daenerys Targaryen
from Game of Thrones don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to our
channel if you want more videos about My
Little Pony today we're checking out 10
My Little Pony character's reimagined as
celebrities kylie jenner since my little
pony's motto is friendship is magic
we're sure kylie jenner would be a
perfect addition to the show as one of
the youngest celebrities to make the
Forbes 100 celebrity list in 2017 Kylie
Jenner has proven that she's not just
another Kardashian not only is she
totally gorgeous but Kylie is also a
social media star with a large following
and a businesswoman with her own
cosmetics line over the years she's
shown us many different fashion looks
but this proves that she looks good in
basically anything
check out this My Little Pony character
reimagined as kylie jenner it looks just
as fabulous as Kylie herself and we love
the added diamond bling do you think
she'd be as friendly as the rest of the
My Little Pony crew we're sure Kylie
would bring a unique character to the My
Little Pony show and we bet it would be
one of the most watched episodes ever
speaking of the Kardashians here's a My
Little Pony version of Kylie's
half-sister Kim who's up for Keeping Up
with My Little Pony series Melanie
Martinez
you might remember Melanie Martinez as
one of the finalists on the 2012 season
of The Voice USA since then this
songstress has been pretty busy and
managed to gain a huge fan base that
appreciates her unique look and sound
and when we say unique look we really
mean
weak from her half pink half dark hair
all the way to her wonderful fashion
sense
Melanie's look is definitely admired by
many speaking of her unique look we
managed to find several versions of her
as a My Little Pony character check
these out the first two belonged to
Santa Maus 23 on deviantART doesn't it
look perfect the pink and black look
represent Melanie Martinez's hair and
we're loving the stylish asked but not
least is Rosie Marie 15 whose version is
totally out of this world we bet Melanie
Martinez appreciates these illustrations
and we'd love to actually see her
character on the actual show Justin
Bieber and how could we forget about the
leader of the belieber army Justin
Bieber has been making best-selling hits
for a very long time
Justin definitely has some unique
characteristics when it comes to his
looks you can immediately recognize him
by his hair as well as his fashion don't
you think the pony called rarity looks
awfully similar to Justin's look from
one of his tours we also found this
illustration created by vector brony on
deviantART this Pony is totally rockin
Justin Bieber's hair and we love it our
next illustration belongs to an artist
called Sarah Liu and we believe it's the
one that resembles Justin Bieber the
most we love the detail of the
microphone and the iconic Justin Bieber
hair
speaking of Justin Bieber do you know
that his mentor is actually Will Smith
the two have a very special bond and
will is encouraging Justin to be his
true self his actual father is a former
MMA fighter which proves that strength
lies in Justin's genes
even so we'd love to see Justin on a
show like my little pony where he proved
that friendship really is magic Nicki
Minaj next on our list is the Queen of
wrap herself the one and only Nicki
Minaj's flawless looks are always a
subject of discussion and we're in love
with her unique fashion she's taking the
world by storm and her fan base is one
of the biggest we've ever seen this
might also be the reason why we man
to find so many My Little Pony versions
of the queen of rap the first
illustration is a slightly angry version
of Nikki with half blonde half pink hair
and a tattoo on her leg we told you it's
nothing like we've ever seen before
this illustration belongs to a
deviantART user called captivating
mystery our next illustration belongs to
aldo brony JDC this Pony comes from
Nicky's the pinkprint album era and we
are digging the colorful style mixed
with black and pink check this out
doesn't nikki actually look like the
fluttershy Pony she's wearing the same
colors we also managed to find a
real-life My Little Pony version of
Nicki and she looks fabulous
speaking of Nicki did you know that she
made history by having seventy six of
her songs hit Billboard's Hot 100 she's
also on the soundtrack for Despicable Me
2 so who knows we might see her as a My
Little Pony character in the future Lady
gaga
speaking of popular characters in My
Little Pony world we hope you're ready
for this one Lady Gaga is one of the
most popular artists on the planet and
you never know what to expect from her
did you know that born this way was
actually inspired by the My Little Pony
toys she's been spotted holding them as
a part of her fashion we also found her
actual My Little Pony toy and it looks
just as fabulous as Gaga herself and
here she is reimagined as one of the
ponies this illustration belongs to brow
n2o and we can definitely see a
character like this in the actual world
of magical ponies in fact there is a
character that looks almost identical to
Lady gaga
her name is countess coloratura and her
looks have often been compared to gaga
herself
we can totally see why the Queen of Pop
chose to get inspired by the show they
definitely share the same fashion sense
speaking of gaga did you know that she
actually dyed her hair blonde after
people confused her with Amy Winehouse
she wanted to make sure she's known for
her own look and over the years it's
something she definitely achieved we
totally love that she draws inspiration
from My Little Pony
Jennifer Lawrence and who can forget
about one of the quirkiest actresses out
there Jennifer Lawrence made her first
acting debut when she was just 14 in a
series called the Bill Engvall show but
she's best known for her role as Katniss
Everdeen from The Hunger Games we found
quite a few versions of her reimagined
as a My Little Pony character here she
is with braided hair and her outfit from
the arena and here's another one
designed by cheese lover 25 this Pony
version of Katniss is showing off her
archery skills and we're digging the
added unicorn horn and last but not
least it's this awesome drawing which
belongs to a deviantART user Libby all
these ponies definitely look ready for
action and we wonder how they'd cope in
the my little pony world which is
slightly less aggressive can you imagine
what would happen if my little pony
characters entered the Hunger Games
arena
Jayla herself would actually struggle to
fit in with the rest of the ponies when
she was in preschool she wasn't allowed
to play with the other girls because she
was too rough poor Jen we're still
hoping for that my little pony
appearance Rianna you can't deny that
Rianna is one of the biggest pop singers
of all time over the past few years
Rihanna has made a huge name for herself
in the music industry RiRi has sported
many iconic looks over the years but her
red hair era has to be our favorites we
managed to find an illustration of her
look in a My Little Pony version and
it's absolutely fabulous this little
pony belongs to captivating mystery on
deviantART we love its red hair and the
pink outfit check out this fan made
Rihanna album cover with Twilight
Sparkle RiRi is definitely a popular
artist and we can't wait to see more My
Little Pony fan art that shows off
Rihanna's different looks did you know
that Rihanna actually has a fashion line
it's called
fenty by Puma Fenty comes from Rihanna's
actual last name and her full name is
Robyn Rihanna Fenty she says that if you
want to get her attention you need to
call her Robyn RiRi is no stranger to
fashion statements and we bet she'd be
able to draw a lot of inspiration from
my little
pony characters Katy Perry speaking of
fashion statements and embracing an
eccentric style Katy Perry is also no
stranger to unique looks in fact some of
her looks definitely remind us of my
little pony like her blue and purple
hair that could easily be inspired by
the one and only Twilight Sparkle this
deviantART user took it a step further
and changed her look into a complete My
Little Pony character isn't it totally
fabulous one of Katy's many looks has
also been compared to a character called
vinyl and we definitely see the
resemblance and here's a Katy Perry
album cover art created by Adrian Impala
Mota we bet you can pair up any pony
character with a Katy Perry look and
make it look good did you know that katy
perry's full name is katherine elizabeth
hudson she changed it to Katy Perry to
avoid any confusion with the popular
actress Kate Hudson along with other
records Katy Perry also holds a world
record for having the most Twitter
followers she is so popular my little
pony cast themselves made a cover of her
california girls' song we're telling you
a Katy Perry appearance in My Little
Pony is going to happen one day
we can't wait to see it Harry Styles
when it comes to popular male artists
you can't deny it that Harry Styles is
definitely the one to look out for
Perry's singing talent has put him on
the music charts as a solo artist and as
a member of the former band One
Direction the One Direction fan base is
still strong as ever and we managed to
find several illustrations of Harry in
the My Little Pony world can you
recognize him from this picture it was
created by a deviantART user fjc and we
love this attention to detail here's
another version capturing Harry's curly
hair
this illustration belongs to the
mentalist LPS we have another one for
you on this picture done by MS creepy
Perry is clearly still a part of One
Direction one of the most popular boy
bands of their time did you know Harry
was in a band before he joined
one direction it was called white Eskimo
sure it wasn't as popular as one
direction but it consisted of Harry's
friends this is exactly why we can
easily see Harry fitting in the My
Little Pony world Daenerys Targaryen yes
that's right we're about to dive into
the world of Game of Thrones it's hard
to believe a show like My Little Pony
would ever merge with the intense world
of Game of Thrones but the show's
devoted fans made it happen
Daenerys is a very popular character we
found several versions of Daenerys as a
My Little Pony character and they're all
looking fierce and ready for action
check these out
this first belongs to Jill pantos II and
her version of Daenerys is pretty
realistic it looks like it's already sat
in the Game of Thrones world and this
blonde haired pony seems like it's ready
for battle next illustration belongs to
a deviantART user called restless who
brilliantly portrayed Daenerys with her
three dragons
we loved her white hair and the fire
dragon detail can you imagine this Pony
interact with someone like Twilight
Sparkle but wait we're not done yet
here's another illustration for you this
character appeared in one of the My
Little Pony comic books and while it
doesn't have a name fans have noticed
the resemblance to Daenerys Targaryen
we totally see it which celebrity would
you want to see as a My Little Pony
character let us know and don't forget
to subscribe for more videos like this
one check out 10 Disney Princesses
reimagined as My Little Pony see you
next time
[Music]